the Joe Rogan experience tick-tock-tick
you don't know about tick-tock I know
about for my kids they do the tick I
don't know what it is it's like
live-streaming dancing from what I
understand I know it only from
Christina's page cuz she puts on some oh
yeah it started as a music app called
musically I changed the name to take
only people dancing it's a lot of kids
kids are all over it but you don't want
to talk or be funny now become what vine
was but it's still based around music
wasn't vine only like five seconds and
this is a little bit longer but there's
a lot of songs over the last year that
have gotten popular off there including
like Old Town Road which is the number
one song oh yeah I got popular off of
there off of that's how it got popular
Wow well I've got popular with my kids
for sure my kids knew about that song
way before me they were singing it you
never see that there's a video of little
nas X whatever his name is at a school
and he's on stage and these kids are
singing along it is [ __ ] adorable Oh
sing along to the song it's really cute
song he's doing one with Dolly Parton I
think and what was this the controversy
they wouldn't let the song be on the
country charts that was the big
controversy races that's [ __ ] racist
that's all it is that is a goddamn
country song and not Garth Brooks that
other guys Cyrus is honorably ready yeah
yeah well they once they put him on then
it they allowed it on the country charts
he wasn't in the original version so
they had to put him on it am I wrong
about that you are correct well you know
but Hootie and Hootie was this hunt
country singer yes but he started out as
a regular singer and then came over at
the country
yeah his career kind of fell apart as a
punk movie and the Blowfish went away
Darius Rucker yes thank you he's really
good [ __ ] he's got a beautiful voice of
all the things I remember and he may be
just that's his [ __ ] he's into it but
his career was floundering in the other
world and then he went into the world of
hay and flannel and they took off I
[ __ ] drive home to a lot of his music
Hollow I don't know why that food and
the Blowfish was a legit Jam I wonder
why they didn't last right they're on
tour again right now
Oh hmm doesn't say but Aaron Lewis
abstained also singer oh he's a huge oh
he's good he wears Magga hats and he's
got don't tread on me tattooed on his
neck that was like during the time of
him nice guy we're like all the bands
were like like there was like a moment
where that's what all the music sound
like yeah and maybe that just one's like
Train Toad the Wet Sprocket yeah the
[ __ ] didn't he just got sick of it the
band Pearl Jam they're all Pearl Jam
groans best that's what it is but yeah
man such a good song yeah it's great I
mean that is so crazy when I think about
that Jeremy spoken song I had no white
like it was so weird when it came out
Ike had no concept of what it even
[ __ ] meant no I was listening it was
on mix the other day and I was like was
it about suicide didn't wasn't about a
kid that that blew his head off in
Jeremy spoke in class today I think he
blew his brains out in class remember
that video is [ __ ] sinister it's
about suicide
yeah I didn't make out to a suicide song
okay no idea what he's even about yeah
there's a lot of really McCobb [ __ ]
going on back down with music remember
that was that silver chair member that's
silver chair videos wanna rape me how
about that literally forgot about it
until just this moment rape me my friend
used to dance to it she's a drink to it
smoke weed to it we used to sing along
if it was on tick tock now we'd be
singing along to it
what crazy [ __ ] wild who would be the
Kurt Cobain of today like what that was
such a big deal like who would it can't
have that with the internet there's
someone would me to him they'd find out
[ __ ] about him there'd be a dick pic
yeah people get are sure I mean he had
poor judgment he dated Courtney Love he
married her right but like when he
killed his definitely taking pictures of
his dick
[Applause]